being the mother of black children in
America debt today is so scary
especially if you have males and even
females you want to protect your
children as much as you can you want to
be there with them every step they take
our lives have been so devalued that is
scary because you don't know if they're
going to come home all you do is you
hope and you pray you know that they
come back through that front door the
same way they walked out of it so I'm
wearing these pants because I really
want the Justice Department to really
take action on the officer who killed
our gardener the officer who killed my
son and the officer who killed Michael
Brown Oscar's death has impacted us
tremendously Oscar would do whatever my
mom wanted him to do he loved to call
his granny granny you know he would cut
her grass for her you know he painted
for her if you were down he would you
know mom is everything is gonna be all
right you know we got to make it my
response to all the people out on the
streets protesting I'll think about when
Martin Luther King and they marched in
Birmingham I think about how they had a
objective of getting something changed
and that is what we have to do as we
protest have a strategy of mine one of
the goals is to bring to America to let
them know that there is a problem with
dehumanizing black and brown lives there
is a problem in the judicial system it's
not fair and we want to change around
the United States there is outrage over
the police shooting of Michael Brown in
Ferguson Missouri maybe because
it isn't the first time an unarmed black
man has been gunned down by cops